mad et qu'il est parti
quand il est parti
à son dernier souffle je suis parti à
près de l'hôpital pourtant j étais tous
les jours jamais la tour eiffel s'est
illuminé et pourtant tous les jours gt1
et le jour où il est mort je suis sorti
j'étais avec mon amie muriel la tour
eiffel est éliminé et et la tour eiffel
c'était très important pour tous les
deux parce que c'était notre première
rencontre pour le restaurant donc pour
toi tu es tu te tue les prix comment je
me suis dit voilà chérie je suis là
t'inquiète pas on regarde notre tour
eiffel jeu l'éclair pour toi je prends
la voiture
elle était au moins deux au parking et
je démarre la voiture pourtant moins de
on capte pas la musique de johnny
hallyday musique que je faisais écouter
quand tu étais pas dans le coma mais en
semi sommeil musique de john et
le lendemain je dis à mon amie muriel va
falloir trouver un mot de code pour
pâques
il ya des gens mal intentionnés qui
veulent faire des photos sur le lit de
mort de jean-pierre faire très attention
aux funérailles funérarium donc j'ai dit
on va mettre un mot de passe et puis moi
je sais pas je sais pas pourquoi mais je
pensais la nature je dis bah on va dire
le mot sapin et là ma copine me regarde
ça c'est glauque sapin comme moi je dis
ah bah oui c'est vrai t'as raison pardon
va peut-être pas mettre sapin on
trouvera autre chose je prends la
voiture je vais à l'hôpital pour aller
voir mon jean pierre était plus là mais
voilà près de lui et je garde la voiture
au parking à pompidou encore une fois je
sors de la voiture on a mis elle sort
aussi est là deux branches de morceaux
de sapins sur la roue arrière gauche un
truc de dingue rome et s'est ensuite ma
fille
avant de m'endormir jeudi jean-pierre
j'aimerais bien que tu me fasses un
signe là j'ai besoin j'ai besoin sans
doute de celui par les contenus j'ai pas
beaucoup moi j'ai fait que ça va le tout
comme ça tu es dans la chambre d'une
amie je m'en fous pibor alain moi je
suis pas logique et voilà ça ça va te
perds ça va pas de plaire tu parles
comme ça tout seul tu ne t'es pas tout
seul mais pour nan chen hong mais on
n'est pas tout seul personne était donc
tu dis ouais jean-pierre j'aimerais bien
qu'ils le fassent en signe ce soir oui
donc j'ai été vers minuit et demi un
truc comme ça je dis moi que tu me
fasses asim que ça fait un petit peu
longtemps là et puis bon je commence à
m'endormir et là j'ai ma fille qui me
téléphonent à 1h15 du matin maman maman
papa m'a fait ainsi il m'a fait un signe
soit pas de la chance je vais demander
avant de m'endormir il l'a fait pour toi
m dit oui mais j'étais avec ma copine
dans mon salon parce qu'elle elle a pris
un appartement et et ont discuté avec ma
copine la télé s'est allumée et il y
avait un film il ya le comédien qui dit
je suis fier de toi ma fille la télé
c'est tes potes
et ma fille m'a dit maman maman maman et
après le monfils il était en était un
peu en colère parce qu'il n'y aurais je
comprends pas moi j'ai pas de signe
c'est des conneries et tout ça et touche
parce que tu les vois pas il faut être
prêt il faut les voir et pendant le
débat présidentiel
gens comme il a aidé parce que j'ai mis
une grande photo dans mon salon de
jean-pierre et tous et tom n'arrêtait
pas de dire papa fais moi un signe pas
pas fait - si le pape a fait -6 et
lâchez pas j'imite homme laisse le
tranquille la finance je veux un signe
je veux un signe et au bout d'une demi
heure il y avait là t-il donc lui dès la
télé dans le salon et moi j'étais dans
ma chambre en train de regarder la télé
le débat et la télé s'est arrêtée arrêt
sur images au bout d'une demi-heure et
moi ma télé avait sur image fedom je
suis en train de regarder les élections
qu'est ce que tu as fait tu me salis
j'ai eu mon signe papa il a fait arrêter
la télé et après linz il dit peut passer
vosges et on signe la télé c'est remy
normalement en marche sauf que la mienne
elle est restée bloquée sur tf1 j'ai pas
pu regarder continue sur tf1 mais j'ai
pu regarder sur la deux non c'est faux
mais le truc dément et il y avait un
autre truc aussi très flagrant j'ai fait
un rêve
j'étais avec jean-pierre y conduisait
sur l'autoroute
et jeudi mais mr mais comment je vais
lui dire qu'il est mort parce qu'il sait
pas qu'il est mort et puis on va avoir
un accident de voiture mais je peux pas
lui dire qu'il est mort il ne s'est même
pas et puis rigolent ils roulent en
voiture et tout comment je vais lui dire
que manger et puis je me réveille
subitement je fais tiens c'est bizarre
il va se passer quelque chose et j'étais
à lille chez des amis je dormais chez
des amis parce que j'étais allé pour un
salon du livre et donc j'en parle à mes
amis je leur explique et je dis bah il
va se passer quelque chose aujourd'hui
donc je vais au salon du livre je
commence à signer d'autographes et où il
ya un monsieur qui vient vers moi une
qui vous savez qu'il ya une voyante qui
est lâche-t-il avant le salon de lille
fait mouiller les derrières cacher mon
la voit pas trop moi de mamie elle m'a
dit des choses surprenantes j'ai planté
tous les gens pour les autres nona je
suis désolé je m'absente dix minutes
c'est sûr que j'ai un gel va devoir me
donner un message je vais l'avoir donc
qu'elle me voit elle et elle commence à
pleurer elle m'a dit tellement c'est bon
ça c'est facile à dire mais elles disent
ça fait une semaine que je savais qu'on
allait se rencontrer et j'ai dit oui bah
alors j'ai dit vous avez des messages je
clarifie la pauvre jeune un peu
traumatisés et elle me dit oui déjà le
premier message il a enfin compris qu'il
était mort et moi dans la nuit je me
suis dit merde il a pas compris c'est
pas qu'il est mort et j'ai dit il ya
autre chose elle me dit oui elle hier il
a en train de me dire que ce cas elle
rigolé après en même temps au moment où
il est parti il dit et oui tu avais
encore raison et c'est la phrase que je
lui ai dit et c'est la phrase que je lui
ai dit à jean pierre quand il est parti
je lui dis tu verras ton âme sera là
haut que tu me diras merde elle avait
encore raison donc elle a véhiculé ça
c'est quand même incroyable
et elle m'avait parlé aussi d'une montre
une dit wim parle d'une montre qu'il
faut pas oublier de la donnée de la
donner à 20 ans et je sais qu'il avait
une montre qu'il aimait bien jean-pierre
et qu'il voulait que tom les pour 50 ans
parce qu'il a dit là c'est un peu jeune
pour la voir donc en fait comment il
peut avoir tous ces signes comment elle
a pas lu dans mes pensées après j'ai été
voir aussi bruno qui parle bruno un
message qui parle avec les morts donc ça
fait bizarre quand on dit ça moi la
toute première fois quand on lit ça j'en
ai hâte de voir les données par des
témoins alors y est donc il m'a je peux
pas tout vous raconter mais tout de
suite il m'a montré bien qu'il était là
il dit oui il en train de me dire qu'il
était très fier de ce que votre fils ou
il m'a dit exactement ce qui avait mis
dans le cercueil sur la dans la poche
gauche et il est très fier et ses îles
ç'aurait pu être moi sa première fille
son fils tom non c'était sa fille tout
était très fier qui le remercie et
c'était exact et plein d'autres choses
qui étaient exactes mais il y aurait
deux ferrari va vivre comme ça on se
dise on sait si c'est oui parce que je
sais que lui ça doit leur assurer aussi
fait excuser moi me dire ceinture pour
une fois le message ne le rassure et
aussi parce que ils n'arrêtent pas quand
je reçois des messages ou des voyants
qui n'arrête pas de demander pardon
pardon ne pas m'avoir cru pardon de 2,7
moquer d'un peu de mon livre parce qu'il
a eu le temps de lire mon livre aussi
moi j'y crois justement je parlais de ça
c'est quand même impressionnant d'avoir
osé écrire ce livre qui est sorti en
octobre et qu'il est parti là en mars
alors on va rappeler le livre 1 nathalie
pour nos téléspectateurs à mais c'était
moi j'y crois chez merci moi j'y crois
chez trédaniel oui où tu disais donc je
parle de mésanges de mai prémonition
c'est comme ça que j'ai pu sauver
plusieurs fois l'avis de jean-pierre bon
n'a jamais pu lui dire il passerait pas
ses 72 ans était c'était impensable que
je lui dise sauf à des amis proches pour
qu'on voit que je suis pas folle et ce
que je ressens et c est réel
donc voilà donc il avait lu ce livre est
des fois il se moque un peu de moi et me
dit ah ouais c'est un peu bizarre un ton
truc et toi je dis ouais mais j'étais
sauvé la lie quand même non et ouais non
c'est vrai je dis tu as pu aller voir
ton frère grâce à moi parce que je
savais j'ai donné à la date exacte de la
mort de son frère dont il avait pu voir
son frère aussi d'une vo et non c'est
vrai c'est vrai je suis tu leur as plus
tard tu verra plus tard
et donc c'est bizarre qu'il a lu ce
livre et que ça se passe maintenant il
n'ya pas de ya pas de hasard moi je dis
qu a pas de hasard une façon se
rencontrent tous là haut après qu'en
soient juifs musulmans catholiques c'est
tous pour tout le monde pareil c'est fou
non ce que tu nous racontes ce qu'on se
dit ça doit être non pas en avoir peur
non non non parce que les gens qui
veulent communiquer avec vous c'est
c'est important parce que eux ils sont
très bien là où c'est ce qu'on nous dit
et s'ils sont dans la lumière ils font
plein d'autres choses après là haut donc
non non ils sont très très bien et c'est
vrai moi pour m'endormir enfin c'est
tout con mais j'écoute toujours sur des
sur youtube des trucs et emi les gens
qui étaient killy qui sont partis mais
qui sont revenus en fin qui va par
exemple un arrêt cardiaque mais ils sont
revenus ou pendant une opération est
tout et racontent tous la même chose et
on a de plus en plus 7000 au moins deux
cas par an en france le mort imminente
alors imminente et
en plus vous avez pardon oui notion oui
c'est bouleversant votre témoignage sur
la force de l'amour et de la
spiritualité est ce que parfois il
s'adresse directement à vous ou est ce
que dans la vie quotidienne vous faites
quelque chose et vous dit tiens c'est
lui qui a dû m'inciter à faire ça
la dernière fois le truc bête je lui
parle du dimanche j'espère que je serai
à la hauteur pour les études des enfants
mon cv je dis comme ça ça coûte cher et
tout mais bon on y arrivera et tout y'a
pas de soucis et tout et puis je vais
dans ma cuisine et puis j'entends dans
la voix va dans la bibliothèque va dans
la bibliothèque je me tue ce que je dis
en moi je suis dit mais qu'est ce que tu
veux que j'aille faire qu'est ce qui me
paraît enfin c'est un truc qui me dit
pourquoi aller dans la bibliothèque donc
je dis bon je vais dans la bibliothèque
et je prends un livre il ya une grande
bibliothèque j'ai choisi un livre il y
avait 500 euros en liquide dedans
un truc de dingue j'ai appelé mon fils
ma fille je vais regarder c'est un truc
de dingue c'est bien
cette année dans la bibliothèque
[Rires]
du tout ni moins de
15000 euros moi je suis parle beaucoup
je ne suis pas dans des files en gueule
aussi parce que y'a mon fils il fait les
courses de bagnoles et puis il y avait
deux courses de voitures à faire et je
savais que pour mon fils est elle très
important qu'ils gagnent cette course
parce qu'ils avaient envie de remettre
cette coupe au cimetière et là j'ai pas
compris là c'est la première course
s'est retrouvé dernier choses qui
arrivent rarement en général il peut
être dans les dix premiers mais là
dernier donc je me mets dans mon coin et
jean-pierre qu'est ce que tu fais là tu
protèges pas ton fils mais merde tu te
rends compte pour eu la déception si
vous gagnez cette coupe c'est pour toi
donc tes intérêts de remuer le popotin
pour pour la prochaine course dont qui
part il n'était pas dans les dents les
premiers part je suis plus dans 15e
position et où il part égale la course
non c'est fou et cette course là elle
n'avait jamais gagnant il avait déjà été
2e 3e et jean persyn bouger le popotin
et voilà c'est mon chef